[Musica]
sempre più si parla della necessità di
investire sull'infrastrutturazione
sociale del mezzogiorno come base per lo
sviluppo sostenibile del territorio
del resto è semplice e cinesi resi conto
senza coesione sociale
non si può parlare di sviluppo se n'è
già dibattuto e lo sappiamo il pil non è
un buon indicatore ad esempio per andare
a vedere lo stato di benessere di una
comunità
eppure proprio su indicatori come il
pilot il tasso di occupazione che
andiamo a misurare a definire le
politiche di sviluppo e crescita dei
territori 70 anni di piani con il sud
con invece ingenti investimenti non
hanno portato a tutto questo è un
miglioramento della qualità della vita
delle persone che vivono nel mezzogiorno
ebbene non è un problema di mala
gestione dei fondi o di incapacità di
giudizio da parte dei decisori nazionali
ma lo vediamo anche nelle nostre
comunità
quante volte ci sentiamo dire eh ma
porta del lavoro crea posti di lavoro e
allora va bene costruire porti o
industrie dal dubbio impatto ambientale
infrastrutturare turisticamente le
nostre cose privatizzando rifatto alle
spiagge oppure sempre parliamo delle
spiagge mettere il parcheggio a
pagamento perché così possiamo creare un
posto di lavoro
beh bene e siamo disposti a fare grandi
investimenti ea fare grosse rinunce
anche in termini di beni comuni
sull'altare dello sviluppo economico
come se sviluppo economico e sviluppo
ambientale e sociale non potessero
andare di pari passo
come se non ci fossero delle forme per
cui economia società potessero lavorare
insieme verso un concetto più ampio di
sviluppo
proviamo quindi per una volta a partire
dal sociale come molti suggeriscono
quello che vi vorrei raccontare oggi è
un esperimento di infrastrutturazione
sociale che stiamo portando avanti nel
sarrabus una piccola area del sud est
della sardegna 80 chilometri da cagliari
un investimento che non parte da como
o dall'asse o dalle imprese ma parte
dalle associazioni da quello che è il
cuore del terzo settore che nel sarrabus
sono essenzialmente a sette piccole
associazioni una ogni 80 abitanti che
abbiamo provato a dire mettiamoci
insieme
proviamo a fare qualcosa di diverso
uniamo energie competenze vediamo dove
possiamo arrivare
per generare un impatto positivo per la
comunità che questo significa migliorare
l'offerta di attività e servizi non solo
assistenziali dare una rappresentanza
organizzata di bisogni sociali andare a
concorrere insieme agli enti pubblici ei
privati alle polia alla definizione
delle politiche di investimento e di
sviluppo
questa esperienza nasce nel 2019
l'occasione è stata la partecipazione un
bando e qui vorrei fare una piccola
premessa nelle nostre comunità anche
quelle delle aree più interne e quelle
più piccole a mancare molto spesso non
sono le risorse in termini di capitale
umano capitale sociale e anche capitale
economico che lo si può andare a
ricercare attraverso investitori
certamente molto spesso quella che manca
è la volontà la volontà di generare un
cambiamento per che cosa succede che ci
si trova soprattutto che ha potere
decisionale
il presidente dell'associazione il
sindaco ma anche rappresentante di
qualche ente territoriale un po più
grosso ci si trova molto spesso a dire
sì le cose non vanno bene però è bello
deresponsabilizzarsi dare la colpa a
qualcun altro e non dover ammettere che
forse quel cambiamento lo si deve
portare avanti
essi stessi rinunciando a qualcosa e
rinunciando a qualcosa significa
veramente dire la situazione così com'è
non può funzionare e per noi la
situazione così com'è non può funzionare
dal fatto che un territorio dove c'è
un'associazione ogni 80 abitanti la
media nazionale 1 ogni 50 vuol dire che
è un territorio che è assai frammentato
dove nessuno è in grado di avere una
base sociale abbastanza forte in termini
di risorse da sviluppare per andare a
fare un intervento incisivo per cui
mettiamoci assieme rinunciamo a degli
spazi per mettere qualcosa attorno
un'idea un'idea comune nuova di sviluppo
e questo significa scrivere un progetto
da presentare un bando non richiedere un
contributo scrivere un progetto a dire
la situazione così com'è non funziona
io ho un'idea di cambiamento e so come
portarla avanti e allora sì riesco ad
attirare le risorse economiche perché
quelle sociali quelle umane ce li ho già
in casa e ci siamo dati un obiettivo
ambizioso un'idea di cambiamento creare
le condizioni affinché tutti senza
escludere nessuno possano aspirare e
realizzare i propri sogni i propri
desideri in una dimensione collettiva in
cui tutti possono essere protagonisti
con le loro capacità e competenze di un
processo di sviluppo di benessere
collettivo
sicuramente un obiettivo ambizioso ma
che vuol dire essenzialmente coinvolgere
e rendere protagonisti tutti e perché
siamo partiti dalle associazioni perché
l'associazione è il luogo naturale dove
le persone entrano e fanno qualcosa
perché si sentono realizzate perché
credono in quello che fanno e ritengono
che mettendosi assieme unendosi si possa
raggiungere un obiettivo comune e quindi
è la volontà la volontà di mettersi
assieme
quello che conta è quello che fa la
differenza
siamo partiti così e dovevamo trovare un
modo una modalità per coinvolgere le
persone e renderle partecipi e renderle
protagoniste e l'ispirazione è venuta da
una pratica che avevamo già in casa non
serviva andare fuori a cercarla o
aspettare che arrivasse qualcuno imporla
a mano la juta un manu torna da ti do
qualcosa e in cambio tu mi dai
qualcos'altro è così che obbligo a
partecipare al processo perché non è più
una questione uno verso chi ma è una
persona una questione uno contro uno e
proviamo a fare quel passo in più
rendiamola su una dimensione comunitaria
l'associazione fa qualcosa per te perché
tu non puoi fare qualcosa per gli altri
partiti non puoi fare qualcosa per
un'altra associazione perché siamo una
rete magari tu puoi accettare o avere
bisogno dei servizi e delle attività di
una ti possono fare piacere però magari
le tue capacità e le competenze possono
essere spese
altrove e questa è la forza della rete
di una rete di associazioni chi seppur
piccole e diversificate offrono tanto e
dall'altro possono dare ampi spazi di
protagonismo questa però è ancora
reciprocità condizionata faccio qualcosa
affinché tu faccia qualcos'altro e e più
proprio di una transizione economica che
di un processo di sviluppo di comunità
sinceramente la il passaggio ulteriore è
ragionare su un presupposto di
reciprocità incondizionata ma allora
cos'è che spinge un volontario a fare
delle attività perché si spende al di là
di quanto riceve perché crede forme
fermamente in quello che fa si sente
realizzato e lo fa come vuole lui vi
sfido a far accettare a qualche
volontario un protocollo ha imposto dove
deve fare delle cose come in una
fabbrica una sequenza meccanica di
attività da rispettare pedissequamente
non funziona così scappano i volontari
per cui usiamo la leva di a manu torna
da ma proviamo coinvolgere le persone
non guardiamo più i beneficiari delle
nostre attività dei nostri servizi come
dei beneficiari
scusate il gioco di parole ma guardiamo
le come volontari che potrebbero
spendersi a favore della comunità e
facciamolo guardandolo guardandoli come
delle persone come delle persone che
hanno delle aspirazioni dei desideri e
dei sogni che se noi riusciamo a
intercettare riusciamo anche a orientare
verso uno sforzo di collettività verso
la creazione di un beneficio comune e
questo è un po anche la forza delle
nostre comunità
per una volta nel paese dove tutti sanno
tutto di tutti conoscere la storia
dietro una persona significa poter
andare in profondità sapere quali sono
le sue competenze le sue capacità sapere
dove a piacere a spendersi e quindi
proviamo coinvolgerla in un attività che
sicuramente la farà sentire realizzata
in modo che vada oltre la semplice
restituzione dell'aiuto ma diventi
qualcosa di intrinseco che dice sì vabbè
quella cosa piace farla e quindi
continua a farla a prescindere da quanto
sto ricevendo
abbiamo iniziato con un intervento di
rigenerazione urbana in piccolo avevamo
bisogno di costruirci uno spazio che
potesse dare protagonismo sia alle
associazioni ma anche alle persone un
luogo una casa che abbiamo chiamato da
mummia dove ognuno potesse entrare e
accedere sicuramente a un'ampia offerta
di attività ma anche poter dire so fare
questa cosa la voglio fare aiutatemi a
realizzarla perché da questa cosa può
nascere qualcosa per la comunità
mettiamo insieme veramente le energie e
le risorse le competenze come una casa
la costruiamo assieme e ci siamo messi
dotazione finanziaria iniziare a
iniziale 15mila euro
siamo partiti da un immobile da
ristrutturare quindi essenzialmente ci
siamo pagati parte dei materiali
mancavano ancora altri materiali e
manodopera ma proviamo a costruirlo
veramente con la reciprocità questo
edificio prendendo tutti i protagonisti
dell'intervento dicevo come una casa
dove il progetto non è di 1 il progetto
della famiglia qui la famiglia e la
comunità è molto più complesso è
veramente molto più complesso vi dico da
progettista sono trovato a dover
discutere col capo cantiere rispetto a
come organizzare uno spazio e mi ha
detto beh di queste cose non ne devi
parlare con me parlane con daniele è qui
tutti i giorni ci sta lavorando lui in
quell'ambiente
non è che gli si può dire cosa deve fare
precisamente gli do un po di supporto
tecnico cerco che si ha dentro dei
paletti però parla con lui e parlo con
daniele daniele un volontario fa otto
ore di volontariato al giorno ma partiva
come beneficiario era stato aiutato a
prendere il reddito di cittadinanza solo
a gestire la pratica e cosa ci racconta
daniele cosa mi raccontate in
quell'occasione sai prendo il reddito di
cittadinanza cece restituito restituito
l'aiuto che mi avete dato ma cosa dovrei
fare adesso stare sul divano a guardare
la tv almeno qui mi sento utile e poi in
questa sala ci facciamo la cucina io
sono un ex cuoco e quindi diciamo che
cucinare quello che mi piace fare la
faccia mia immagine
somiglianza così poi ci lavoro bene
dentro e bene così abbiamo fatto un
intervento è capito da questo siparietto
che può anche sembrare simpatico ma ci
pone il problema più grande del rendere
tutti i protagonisti che non è
partecipazione
la partecipazione è la reciprocità
condizionata il protagonismo e la recita
incondizionata
perché un conto è devo fare restituire
quello che ho ricevuto e quindi sì mi
attivo e faccio quello che devo fare un
conto è dire vado oltre
divento io diventa quella cosa diventa
anche un po mi ha e ci metto del mio
percepisco in quella cosa del valore
aggiunto
però questo significa che qualcuno deve
fare un passo indietro non si può
sperare che la gente partecipi senza
avere spazi di protagonismo senza poter
incidere anche nei processi decisionali
più semplici essere infrastruttura
sociale vuol dire essere in un sistema
dove ognuno fa un passo indietro lascia
uno spazio di protagonismo ad altri ed è
pronto a mediare le sue posizioni con
tutti a prescindere che sia al
presidente di un'associazione o legale
rappresentante di un'altra si è tutti
partecipi di un processo in cui si deve
essere coprotagonisti e questa è anche
il solito problema di volontà
quanti sono disposti a fare un passo
indietro per cedere spazio di
protagonismo ci siamo resi conto durante
la pandemia durante i mesi del lock down
di quanto sia brutto non essere
protagonisti di quanto non sia piacevole
a dover dipendere dalle scelte di altri
ed essere escluso da tutti i processi
aspettare e vedere quanta frustrazione
dietro ogni dpcm ad aspettare che
qualcuno prenda delle decisioni per
risolvere dei problemi personali e
quindi cosa è successo durante il lock
down c'è stato veramente un boom di
bisogni ma anche un boom di volontari di
persone che hanno detto non ce la faccio
a stare a casa e non fare niente io mi
devo rendere utile devo sentirmi
realizzato in qualche attività e nella
nostra piccola
la struttura sociale questa è diventata
una cosa potentissima perché da un lato
tutte le associazioni hanno saputo
attivarsi e riorientare le proprie
attività verso risposte per bisogni
emergenziali dall'altro un sacco di
persone energie competenze si sono
rimesse in circolo sono entrate a far
parte di questo sistema è di colpo
quella infrastruttura l'abbiamo
terminata di colpo le persone hanno
detto sì mi hai aiutato per quel momento
di difficoltà ma io adesso voglio
continuare a partecipare guarda so fare
questo questo e questo ed altre non
posso partecipare o dei problemi però ho
queste risorse da mettere a disposizione
e allora esempio una persona anziana ha
messo a disposizione un agrumeto una
persona che era un agricoltore che aveva
piacere a fare attività con persone con
disabilità si è messa a disposizione
un'altra associazione che fa attività o
per persone speciali
ha detto bene mettiamoci insieme
costruiamo un agrumeto che sia un
espressione di agricoltura sociale dove
ci lavoriamo insieme
c'è beneficio per i ragazzi e poi perché
no i prodotti gli andiamo a vendere
proviamo ad auto e sostenerci
e così con l'agrumeto così con un
appartamento così che anche con
un'impresa agricola partendo dal sociale
siamo giunti a un economico con una
comunità che è molto più coesa e che ha
voglia veramente di esprimere capacità e
competenze in favore dell'altro senza
andare a vedere cosa l'altro restituisce
e forse questa è l'espressione massima
di sviluppo di comunità e forse questo è
un sinonimo di sviluppo vorrei chiudere
con un'altra cosa che è successa durante
il lock down dopo anni di politiche per
far rientrare i giovani o trattenere i
nostri giovani che scappavano dalle
nostre comunità e se n'è già discusso
quo in questa sede noi giovani non è che
si allontanano dalle proprie comunità in
cerca di un'occupazione sì anche quello
ma vanno in cerca di protagonismo
ebbene molti con la pandemia senza
l'incentivo economico sono tornati e
hanno speso le loro energie a favore
degli altri mettendosi a disposizione
adesso la sfida più grande
anche per questa infrastruttura sociale
e quella di riorganizzare queste energie
provare a trattenerle non aspettare che
passi la pandemia è che queste di
scoppino ma dire possiamo sviluppare
forme di economia dove le tue energie le
tue capacità e le competenze possono
aiutare gli altri e si possono anche
generare un posto di lavoro perché
l'altra cosa non dette che quel progetto
che abbiamo presentato a quel bando è
stato approvato la settimana scorsa
quindi tutto l'impatto è derivato
semplicemente dal voler perseguire
un'idea è da mettersi a disposizione per
farlo adesso
da quel progetto nascono tre posti di
lavoro ma perché non dire che si può
fare di più che si può andare anche
verso forme di partecipazione economica
molto più forte e forse questa è la
nostra più grande sfida come piccola
infrastruttura sociale che è nata da la
volontà di tutti di fare un passo
indietro e lasciare che tutti fossero
protagoniste
[Musica]